the Joe Rogan experience I'm glad you
talk about anxiety I'm glad you talked
about the way you do because I think
you've opened it up for a lot of people
I think you've get you've made it a
subject that's okay to talk about for
someone like you mhm
we're like a cool guy it was a smart
dude who is successful and talks openly
about anxiety and about how it's
affected you that's I think that's a
you're doing a very big service for that
I didn't even know what anxiety was
until 2010 because growing up in the
environment that I grew up and I just
thought all those feelings were normal I
thought all those feelings of paranoia
you know being anxious all the time like
you know and I used to smoke weed so you
know when you smoke weed and you have a
panic attack you just blame it on the
weed yeah I remember driving the Burger
King one time with two of my homeboys
one of them is dead knives names Terrell
rest in peace of mind my man Zeke and I
was high as hell and my steering wheel
needed like steering fluid so it was
shaking so it was shaking my legs and
I'm bugging out just driving the Burger
King a two mile ride I'm like yo what do
y'all got a driver we're all gonna die
right now
take the wheel right now I'm gonna crash
this [ __ ] car tripping the [ __ ]
out and they looking at me like no don't
let this [ __ ] smoke no more but
I had nothing to do with the weed it was
read probably accentuated don't know
definitely did because when I after you
know when I find out what anxiety was in
2010 and I didn't stop going to get you
know corner therapy until like two years
ago cuz back in 2010 when I when I got
diagnosed with my first panic attack
that somebody the doctor was saying hey
this is a panic attack I had just gotten
fired from radio for the fourth
[ __ ] time and I was back at
home living with my mom and like 31
years old with two-year-old daughter and
you know collecting unemployment check
so when I'm having this panic attack and
I go to the doctor and he's like yeah
your heart is fine you got a perfectly
fine heart and you're healthy you got an
athlete's heart he was like yo are you
stressed about anything I'm like [ __ ]
yeah you know so in my mind all I gotta
do is get me another job get back in
position and everything will be okay
yeah but when you get back in position
and you know you've made more money than
you've ever made in your life and you
got books that are selling in TV shows
and all of this other [ __ ] you still
having no same panic attack you like
what the [ __ ] is going on pressure
that's it that's exactly what it is
pressure you think you're gonna lose
everything it's also you experience
pressure that most people will never
experience
you experienced pressure at this this
public scale it's not just pressure it's
pressure with people's eyes on you and
expectations and criticisms and all
these different things that the average
person is not gonna experience that for
millions of people and you do and it's
just like it's always on if you're one
of those crazy [ __ ] it reads comments
good luck lord have mercy
first I used to enjoy cuz I was the guy
who came up on YouTube looking at all
these WorldStarHipHop conspiracy
theories about people and you'd be like
oh my gosh mother [ __ ] sacrifices
hamsters and that's how he got
successful you think all that [ __ ] is
cool until you get older then you start
seeing things about you and you you
laugh at it at first right until you
realize like I'm not a really starting
to say some wild [ __ ] what was the
craziest one that you heard about you I
mean for me you know what it is when
they tried to meet - the [ __ ] tried to
get him out of you know that's that was
that was the most that was the wildest
one to me because I was always the
person I say Livia truth so nobody can
use your truth against you right so it's
not like they brought up anything that I
hadn't spoken about numerous times
before written about in my books they
just decided to attack oh yeah it can
happen it can it so that for me that was
like hi this is going too far but it
didn't it's like you really can't do
anything about it that's the other thing
like there's there's no way to fight it
once the toothpaste is out of the tube
there's no way to put the toothpaste
back in the tube so only thing you could
do is just either let it consume you and
probably ruin you just because you took
it all in you just keep it the [ __ ]
moving like you you know you have to be
confident enough to know what's the
truth and what's not the truth yeah
and so now you don't read any comments
anymore I don't go on Twitter at all put
it through toxic that's it oh yeah we're
in verbally abusive relationships with
our [ __ ] smartphone yeah I agree
yeah it's not it's definitely not
healthy you know we were talking about
it yesterday me and Duncan Trussell we
were saying that it's like your diet
like your diet if you take in junk food
all the time but eat a bunch of shitty
things that are unhealthy it's not good
for your body well your mental diet is
important too if you're always taking in
these toxic arguments and yeah I mean
half a Twitter is just people screaming
at each
just yelling and insulting each other
and trying to find ways in this person's
being shitty or wrong or negative and
it's like that's not real life no the
real life that we experience that were
designed experiences like this people
interacting with it reasonably
it's one of the reasons why I think
people like podcast so much especially
good podcast where people have real
conversations is because you go oh okay
this is this is this is Vitas resonates
with me yeah whereas Twitter does not
resonate with Twitter just gets you
anxious yes you upset yes conversations
where people are actually being nice to
each other in person look at I don't do
podcast over Skype I don't like it I
don't want to see you yes I want you to
be in the room with it I want everyone
to know we're gonna be okay you know
when you when you have these
conversations and people listen to them
like just one on one like this or two on
one this this kind of look what we're
doing now yeah this makes sense to
people
yeah that's one of the reasons when I
when I'm out and about and you know like
when I'm at the airport and somebody
comes up to me and talked to me I speak
to him yeah cuz I feel like that
interaction was supposed to happen right
yes you know what I mean
normal Twitter Instagram I ain't posed
to be talking to you on this [ __ ] yeah
we're not supposed to be human beings
are not wired to be that wired no
everybody should not have that kind of
access to you know so it's just like we
got is we got to take back to see the
facade fall apart when you respond to
one of their tweets like something big
[ __ ] you Charlemagne you ain't [ __ ] and
then you come back why in the bank I'm
just playing bro I'm a fan I didn't
really know it's always that they're
just trying to react just one